ALI AFSHAR: Welcome, everyone,
to the Google Drive Question
Time about the SDK.
Sorry we're a bit late.
We had some minor technical
difficulties,
but we're here now.
My name's Ali.
And this is--
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
I'm Claudio.
ALI AFSHAR: And we're going to
be looking at the questions
that you've been asking on Stack
Overflow, see if we can
come up with some
answers for you.
So the first question we have
is, why is the redirect URL in
Google Drive modified when
an app is called from the
Google Drive UI?
So there's a bit of information
about that, but if
possible, Claudio, you could
describe what a redirect URL
is or what the OAuth flow is.
That would be fantastic.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Sure,
I'll start from that.
But then the spoilers first.
I don't think the redirect URL
is modified by the Google app.
But let's go back to what
a redirect URL is.
So in order for your application
to be authorized
to access the user's files,
the application has to go
through the so-called
OAuth flow.
You've probably seen it many
times, when you install an
application on your
phone, let's say.
And you'll see that the
application wants to access
your files.
So you have to grant access to
it or deny access to it.
And of course, if you
deny access, the
application will not work.
That page is provided
by the OAuth flow.
So when you build your
application and you want to
use this kind of authorization
mechanism, you define some
parameters in the Google
API console.
And one of them is
the redirect URL.
How this works is like this.
The application needs
to be authorized
to access some files.
So it will send the
request to Google.
Google will show you a page that
says what the application
wants, in this case, access
to files or documents.
And it can be read-only,
write-only.
There are different scopes you
can request access to.
And then the user clicks
on Grant Access.
When that happens, Google takes
the user back to the
page that is listed
in the redirect
URL in the API console.
So we don't do any change
to that URL.
We just take it as it
is from the API
console, which you configure.
And we send you back.
What you should do, what you
should make sure, though, is
that these redirect URL that is
defined in the API console
matches the one that
you defined in
your application code.
If they don't match, the OAuth
flow will fail with an error
that is called Redirect
URL mismatch.
And I think this is exactly
what is happening
here in this question.
The developer has defined a
redirect URL that is something
like site.com/app while the
API console says that the
redirect URL is site.com,
without /app.
So there is a mismatch, and for
security reasons we cannot
approve this access,
and the flow fails.
ALI AFSHAR: So the OAuth 2.0
specification is very clear
about this.
You have to check at
each stage that the
redirect URL matches.
So that's just what
we're doing here.
And as Claudio rightly says,
it's likely that
they're not the same.
Now, I have three tips I always
do, because this is an
error that we get quite a lot
when we're writing our own
personal applications.
So I do three things.
Well, the first one, I check
that I haven't made a typo.
The second one is to make sure
that the protocol is right.
So if it's an HTTP redirect,
that's exactly what it is.
It's not an HTTPS redirect.
So check that.
And the third one is to check
trailing slashes.
So if there's a trailing slash
on the end of the URL, that's
not the same as one without.
So I usually check those three
things, and that covers most
minor mistakes that
you can make.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah, just to
make it super clear, it has
to be exactly the same.
It doesn't matter if they start
with the same URL or
they're in the same domain
or anything else.
They have to be the same.
ALI AFSHAR: Yeah.
And if you want more information
on that, please
check out the OAuth 2.0 spec.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: There's also
another thing we can add.
It's that when you define your
application in the API's
console, you can also specify
more than one redirect URL.
And so in the API's console you
define them one per line.
And each of them
would be valid.
Of course, you have to have the
same URL that's in your
application.
But if you need more--
let's say you need more for--
you need one for testing that
is internal only and one for
the public application, the real
application that external
users will use.
Then you can define
both and try.
And that will work same way.
ALI AFSHAR: Absolutely.
And also local host and
this kind of thing
is absolutely fine.
So as long as they match,
you're onto a winner.
So that's, I think, the answer
to that question.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Do we
have other questions?
ALI AFSHAR: We have
other questions.
Another one about OAuth, since
we're warm on the topic.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: OK.
ALI AFSHAR: So I'm having--
oh, clarification on OAuth
flow in Python Google Drive
sample application DrEdit.
DrEdit is an application
that we wrote in a
few different languages.
And it's a full end-to-end
sample that you can use to get
yourself going with
a drive app.
Now, when the application is
called from the Google Drive
UI, the application checks that
it is authorized to make
requests to Google Drive.
In the event that access has
been revoked, it tries to
reauthorize using the
following code.
And how does it do that?
It redirects back to the
authorization endpoint so that
the user can't authorize.
My problem is that when
I revoke access of the
application from my Google
Dashboard and try and open it
via Google Drive UI, it
redirects me to the
Authorization page, then
redirects back to the
application after
I authorize it.
But it manages to retain
the state.
I think this is inconsistent
with what the code describes,
and I was wondering
if there is any
explanation for this behavior.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: I think
that's actually by design.
So let's explain this.
The first time the user opens
your application, the user has
to go through the OAuth flow and
manually grant access to
the application.
When that happens, Google
returns two different tokens--
a long-lived refresh token and
a short-lived access token.
The access token is what you
need to send requests.
And it only lives for about
one hour, though.
So whenever that expires, you
have to use a refresh token to
request a new access token, and
then use the application
as nothing happened.
The problem or the design is
that they only get the refresh
token the first time the user
grants access to the URL.
And then you have
to store it, for
instance, in your database.
And this is what DrEdit,
the app we have, does.
It stores the refresh token
in the database.
In case the database is corrupt,
in case you lose
access to the database, or in
case the user revokes access
to the application,
that refresh token
is no longer valid.
So if the user wants to go back
to the app and use it
again, we have to send
the user back to the
grant access page.
This is not automatic, but
this is covered by the
application.
So it's described in the
documentation we have.
So whenever we realize we have
no refresh token, we have to
send the user back to
a grant access page.
And in order to do that, we have
to build an authorization
URL with some specific
parameters.
After that, the user grants
access, and everything goes
back to the normal flow.
One thing we added to this
normal behavior is that we
save the state.
The state stores some
information about what the
user is doing--
for instance, if the user is
opening a new file, opening an
existing file, or creating
a new file.
We pass that in the
state parameter.
So we want to keep that.
Otherwise, if we don't, then we
have less than optimal user
experience.
Let's say the user is editing
a file, and he spends a long
time writing a document, he
writes this novel, DrEdit.
And the access token expires.
And we need to refresh it
from refresh token.
But for some reason, we
cannot get access to
that refresh token.
We have to send the user back
to the ground access page.
But we don't want the user to
lose what it was doing.
ALI AFSHAR: Exactly.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: So if he was
editing an existing file,
we want the user then to go
back to the same page.
So we send it back to the Grant
Access page, but we also
want the user to go back
to the page it
was working on before.
That's why we store the
state parameter.
ALI AFSHAR: Exactly.
And again, the state parameter
is something that is in the
OAuth 2.0 spec.
And it's very useful for this
purpose, for an application
when the user authorizes to know
what the user was doing
before they were sent
away to authorize.
And in the drive applications
situation, we actually use
that very specifically to
say what it's using.
But in other situations you
can use the state for
whatever you like.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah.
And then the drive application,
when the
application is integrated with
the drive UI, we send some
specific parameters which are
listed in our documentation.
Probably the most important is
the action we pass to the
user, so that when a user tries
to open an existing file
from the drive UI, we pass some
parameters in the state.
There are the action, which
is open, and the unique
identifier, the file the
user's trying to open.
So then the application knows
what user wants to do and
which file the user's
trying to access.
Same thing for when
we create a file.
We say that the action is
create, and we also say where
the user is trying to create,
the folder the user is trying
to create the file in.
ALI AFSHAR: And if you're
interested in how that exactly
look or how to pass that, again,
look at our DrEdit
samples in your chosen language,
and there's an
example of each of them
on how to pass it.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Which are
the languages we support?
ALI AFSHAR: Currently for
DrEdit we have Python.
We have Java.
We have .NET.
We have PHP.
And we have Ruby.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: OK,
what about Go?
I think you wrote one.
ALI AFSHAR: So we do have
half a sample for Go.
We'll look to get that out.
We do have specific samples
for API calling in Go.
So if Go's your thing,
firstly, nice one.
Secondly, check out our samples
that are in our
reference documentation.
I know there's at least one
person using them externally.
So that's great.
I personally love Go.
Right, next question.
How to integrate Google
Docs with PHP?
This seems to be a question
we get asked a lot.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah.
And it's a broad question.
ALI AFSHAR: It's a
broad question.
Please help me--
always a good start--
integrating Google
Docs for PHP.
I want to use Google Docs
as a database for my
application in PHP.
I want to upload and download
files for Google Docs,
irrespective of using PHP.
So I guess that means how do I
access Google Docs with PHP?
Well nowadays--
before I let Claudio answer
this question-- nowadays
Google Docs is Google Drive.
So we would very much recommend
using the Drive API.
And Claudio is going to tell
you a bit about that.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Well, as
you said before, we have
complete samples in many
different languages.
And PHP's one of them.
So the Google Drive API
completely supports PHP.
And we have samples for each
operation, including file
upload and download, which is
[INAUDIBLE], in this case, but
it's also what this guy
is looking for.
And we also have a complete
application, DrEdit.
And we strongly recommend people
to use the new Drive
API, which has a totally new
backend and a new set of
libraries, a new
set of samples.
The existing Documents List
API is still supported.
It also has support for PHP.
But the resources that can be
accessed by the Documents List
API and the Drive API are
exactly the same resources.
So at the moment, right now,
there is no real advantage in
using the old Documents
List API.
Because all of its features are
now supported by the Drive
API v 2, which we released a
couple of weeks ago at Google
I/O.
ALI AFSHAR: Unless you love XML,
for example, or unless
your application is already
heavily integrated with the
Documents List API.
We certainly wouldn't use
it for any new code.
Would you agree with
that, Claudio?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
I would agree.
If you have existing code and
it can be a problem to port
that to the new library and the
new infrastructure, then
of course you can keep using
the Documents List API.
But for new development
we strongly
recommend using Drive API.
It's also more efficient.
It's easier to understand--
and just JSON instead of XML,
and many other advantages.
And of course, we must say that
we now focus more on its
development than the old
version of the API.
ALI AFSHAR: Right.
Absolutely right.
Certainly with new features and
that kind of thing, that's
where we're focused
at the moment.
Uploading a local file
to Google Drive.
I'm looking at code taken from
the official documentation
shown below to upload a file
from the local hard drive to
Google Drive.
Does anyone know what the form
that I would use to post the
necessary JSON and media
would look like?
I've looked high and low
for an example, but
I cannot find one.
I can tell you from the code
sample that he's using Python,
and the sample is exactly copied
from the documentation.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: So
it will be useful.
So this is a general answer.
Any time you report something
on Stack Overflow,
thank you for that.
But also try to be as specific
as possible.
And if something fails, there's
usually an error
message that says a lot
about what went wrong.
So with that, we can
easily help you.
So this user is asking
for the exact JSON
format to upload a file.
So in our code snippets, we have
code snippets for each
language, including
Python, which is
what this guy's using.
But we also have a specific page
for the upload protocol
that describes the JSON that
they have to send, and all the
parameters he can use.
So we have complete samples in
all the supported languages.
But we also have a page that
describes the protocol.
We have actually a different
way to support
files to Google Drive.
And maybe you want to
talk about that?
ALI AFSHAR: Yeah.
I think kind of more interesting
here is exactly
why this sample is failing.
We did speak about the different
upload types in one
of our previous--
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: I see.
ALI AFSHAR: So I don't want
to bore these guys.
But how the DrEdit sample works
is because it's a web
application, and running on App
Engine, there's no concept
of local files.
So this uses an upload type
called the media in memory
upload that essentially takes
a string and a MIME type and
imagines it as a file.
What you would do on a local
file is use a media file
upload that takes a file
name on the local disk.
You can optionally pass it a
MIME type, or it can do the
discovery, work out what the
MIME type is for you.
So I think what would solve this
person's problem is to
actually just replace the media
in memory upload with a
media file upload, and instead
of passing the data as a
string, just to pass the file
name and allow the API library
to do that.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Well,
assuming that the user is not
using App Engine.
ALI AFSHAR: Yeah,
well it says--
very good assumption, but it
says here, "a local file." So
I'm assuming--
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: If you're
using App Engine, can you read
a local file on your computer?
ALI AFSHAR: No.
The App Engine has
no local file.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Exactly.
ALI AFSHAR: And not only
on your system.
On the server itself there's
no concept of file.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: In that case,
I think maybe you have
to upload a file with something
like an HTML upload
to your application and then
send it back to Google.
But it's king of messy, and it's
probably not what this
guy is trying to do.
ALI AFSHAR: So, yeah.
I am fairly sure he's writing
an application that
communicates directly
from his computer--
I keep saying "his"--
his or her computer, directly
to Google Drive, which, of
course, is as common a use case
as doing it from a web
application.
So I think that would be
the solution to that.
If you're interested in the
different types of uploads--
sorry to cut you off
on that, Claudio--
if you're interested in the
different types of upload,
there's the document
Claudio said.
Or check our history of Google
developer live sessions, where
Steve Basil talks in
depth about this.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: I should
probably have checked it out.
Want to go with the
last question?
ALI AFSHAR: And the
last question--
ah, this is a good one.
Because I guess we can
talk about this.
Don't send email notification
when ACL
modified for Google Doc.
That's not really a question,
but I'm guessing it's saying
how can I modify an ACL for a
Google Doc without sending an
email notification.
I'm going to let Claudio answer,
but just as bit of
background, in the Google Drive
user interface, when you
share something with someone you
have a little check box to
say, notify them by email.
And you can set a
custom message.
The API is exactly the same.
By default it does
send an email.
Is that right?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah.
ALI AFSHAR: So is there
a way that we can
not send the email?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yes,
there is a way.
So this user is trying to use
the Documents List API, the
older API, which, I suppose,
is his functionality.
But the Java library, which--
so this developer's
using Java.
And unfortunately,
Java library--
I think it was using Java.
ALI AFSHAR: That's
right, yeah.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Oh yeah.
And unfortunately, Java
client library
doesn't expose this option.
So if you want to use the older
Documents List API with
Java, there's no way to do this,
unless, you hard code at
somewhere--
you have to hack it around.
A better solution would be to
use the new Drive API, which
has an added support for this.
So there's probably called Send
Notification Emails--
there is actually a method, a
set method called Set Send
Notification Emails.
And you can set it to true or
false whenever you instantiate
a insert request.
So this is one of the advantages
of using the new
API, is that the client
libraries are
automatically updated.
So whenever we have a new thing
release in API, a new
feature, a new field, a new
method, in a very short amount
of time all the libraries will
be automatically regenerated
so that users all will have
the latest version of it,
unlike the old ones.
So that is one of the reasons
why we are moving all the APIs
to this new structure.
ALI AFSHAR: And I see in
the comments it says,
unfortunately, my application
is heavily based on
Documents List API.
So exactly that case, as Claudio
said, we would have to
hack around it.
How would you hack around it?
Well, most of the methods you
can pass a URL in directly.
And for that you will need to
manually append the send
notification emails
equals false.
You'd have to actually
concatenate that on
the end of the URL.
So it's not ideal, but that's
the way to do it.
Again, we would strongly
recommend using the Drive API
if you can for this
kind of use case.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah.
All these parameters are
listed in the docs.
So this is found in the
Documents List API
documentation.
So if you want to know what
other parameters are there,
you can just look at the docs.
But take into account that not
all client libraries support
all the same features.
So you can be in a case like
this where the client library
for your favorite language
doesn't actually support the
field or method that
you want--
maybe because it's new, or maybe
because it's something
experimental, or many
other reasons.
When you can, you should
move to the Drive API.
ALI AFSHAR: Agreed And I
think on that note we
should leave it.
Thank you very much
for joining us.
We'll be back again this week
and next with some more of
your questions.
If you have any burning
questions, please, by all
means, ask them.
And we'll get round to answering
them for you.
Thank you very much.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Thank
you very much.
MALE SPEAKER: Good job, guys.
ALI AFSHAR: Thank you.